something called prison food also known
as lunchables
and you want to judge our food [ __ ]
yeah how [ __ ]
dude like lunchables are disgusting
disgusting so when i went back to my
mom's store and i was hungry and
i was like oh quick meal lunchables
eating the cracker i was like what the
[ __ ]
like you can't refrigerate crackers
yo that's [ __ ] dry and the ham is
like you bite through it like
what is this gelatin yeah like holy [ __ ]
like
in five four three two
one hello everybody welcome to another
episode of a genius sabrina podcaster
hello to all my brain farts out there
new listeners and old listeners what up
brain farts that's right my brain farts
i [ __ ] love you to death dude
if i ever meet you in person i'm gonna
put my mouth on your penis
consensually yeah consensually if you
allow
i love you very much you have to say
okay and you have to say okay
then we have to look each other in the
eye and say i love you after and then
you have to kiss me on the mouth after i
put it on your penis
boom well we have another episode of the
genius brain podcast
and in recent news and one of the
funniest things that i've ever seen and
we always see this type of [ __ ]
all the time is somebody trying to take
credit for our asian [ __ ] columbusing
columbusiness you discovered
so if you guys don't know this this
thing is kind of going around right now
and
i talk about kind of like these lunchbox
stories
right yeah and just to reiterate it it's
like when we were kids when we say
lunchbox stories when we were kids
uh as asian americans we would bring
even my might die first at school i
would bring asian food
smells that food is weird or whatever
and well now that people are becoming
foodies
now this food is celebrated and it's
being reintroduced to other people
as if they know more about it when it
was food that we used to be made fun of
yeah well we're seeing this version
again and by a lady who's actually named
karen
shout outs to karen you [ __ ] [ __ ]
cheers [ __ ] so this girl this woman
this karen who is a karen
is basically saying that years ago she
found this miraculous food
called rice porridge right yeah and she
couldn't eat anything so she would eat
rice porridge to make her stomach feel
better
guess what [ __ ] that's asian [ __ ] well
did
do you hear about the backstory of where
she discovered it
from where her like east
east medicine eastern medicine studies
in new mexico [ __ ]
new mexico you know where i learned that
[ __ ] from from my mom
why that's why we got this [ __ ]
chemistry bro yeah
we've been friends for [ __ ] 10 years
seriously so like whenever so in asian
culture right and this goes for anybody
korean japanese vietnamese southeast
asian whatever usually when you're
really sick
you can't really stomach stuff you don't
want to chew things you want something
very mild
well what better source of energy that
you could chew you know eat without
having to chew your food and make your
stomach feel really good
is rice porridge so rice porridge is
essentially that however you do it could
be pre-cooked rice or just
uh rice granules itself that you just
cook in an excess of water yeah
that starch develops and it creates a
porridge almost a risotto but a little
more liquidy
yeah so that's what we eat when we're
sick and we also just eat it as a dish
yeah so this lovely karen learning from
my eastern studies in [ __ ] new mexico
yeah what the [ __ ] are you talking about
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ]
and then over time she took out certain
ingredients that she didn't like to add
in
i don't know [ __ ] rose petals i took
out salt
i took out seasoning and i took out
flavor yeah
you [ __ ] [ __ ] bag and here's the
reason why this [ __ ] is so upsetting
right
it's not the fact that she found this
new food or whatever this
new [ __ ] food this new amazing food
is that she's
repackaging it because it needs to be
redone because it and she's making it
better
yeah what do you mean [ __ ] better
what is this idea
that when you have food from another
culture and you americanize
it you're saying i made it better who
says that that food is [ __ ] better
yeah who the [ __ ] are you to take our
cuisine and say you're making it better
i have no problem people reiterating
food doing dope different [ __ ] with it
but don't say that you're doing [ __ ]
better because you put your filthy
little [ __ ] columbus hands on it you
[ __ ] colonize her
you know the audacity yeah like why
would she say that
i have no [ __ ] clue i mean like the
idea of just discovering a cuisine and
then being like oh
i can sell this in my neighborhood yeah
you know to my friends
they'll they'll want to eat this yeah
and then she wears a kimono while
serving in eggs
she has a [ __ ] asian accent yeah be
someone right here
so much better like [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
it's a weird weird thing for for some
reason these people to feel like oh i
need to
americanize it to better suit other
people's palate
that's also okay with me but don't say
that you made our food which is
perfectly fine and delicious
better yeah better to who [ __ ] you
you don't say that type of [ __ ] it's
offensive yeah it's just that
individualist kind of thing like
you know my friends [ __ ] hate an
apple cabbage so i made this cabbage
out of my grandpapa's [ __ ] lettuce
it's better yeah this kimchi is way
better you know
i mean like it's ridiculous because we
all like i said part of the
asian american experience really is
growing up and being [ __ ] made fun of
for all sorts of reasons maybe your food
stinks maybe they think it's gross your
your eyes are
looks funny your face is flat all these
things and now
it's just really cool and it's hot you
[ __ ]
ate something called prison food also
known as lunchables
and you want to judge our food [ __ ]
yeah how [ __ ] dare dude like
lunchables are disgusting
when i went back to my mom's store and i
was hungry and
i was like oh quick meal lunchables
eating the cracker i was like what the
[ __ ]
like you can't refrigerate crackers
yo that's [ __ ] drunk and the ham is
like you bite through it like
what is this gelatin yeah like holy [ __ ]
like
like white kids are [ __ ] fed this on
the daily
the [ __ ] you know what the crazy
thing is it's like they incepted my mind
so much
whenever i saw a white kid with
lunchables i'm like i won't dab
yeah i've always wanted to beg my
parents for lunchables they're like
all right what the [ __ ] it's gross
realizing
we wanted to fit in yes we didn't really
want to eat delicious
stuff well we thought it was delicious
but not
like we got to fit in lunchables pizza
remember that oh that's lit
lunchables [ __ ] the commercial is
like i can make my own pizza
dude i already know for a fact i love
gina dude gina's my [ __ ] ride or die
[ __ ] i love that cute little vietnamese
skank
she [ __ ] put up a story where she was
like
childhood nostalgia and it was
lunchables [ __ ] pizza
that's [ __ ] white trailer trash
delicacy
this is how i know your tasting food
sucks lady i don't give a [ __ ]
i have nostalgic food too but nothing
like that
yeah i understand where that comes from
but the fact
that this lady who probably grew up
being lunchables her whole life wants to
take porridge which is a delicious food
by the way
[ __ ] cambodian porridge vietnamese
porridge korean pork japanese porridge
actually japanese portuguese don't
really do much with it
yeah the guy just to put the water just
make it a little more wet
i know like japanese food to me is
korean food just less angry
yeah like tenjang
natto like tenjang miso like
yeah that's right yeah so it's always
like less intense
[ __ ] food but this lady i just don't
understand too it's like you should
understand in this climate and the
rhetoric
it started off with the set remember
yeah
the mahjong and then like pha
there's that thing yeah and then like uh
some youtube channel making kimchi and
like i've seen a
food network show where
this guy made kimchi out of apples like
what the [ __ ]
like it makes you like ugh what are you
talking about dude
i'm dude at one point costco was selling
kimchi right so i bought
a jar i mean you know costco size yeah
[ __ ] huge
that what i said earlier was because
there was no napa cabbage in there
yeah it was it was just regular ass
cabbage
and um like different kind of [ __ ]
lettuce and leaves
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know but it was
kimchi like what
yeah yeah yeah it's just this weird
thing that people keep on doing that i i
really don't understand there was this
video that went viral that i was talking
about
not even viral i think it's viral within
la i think people were sending it to me
to make me angry about this lady who is
starting [ __ ]
it's it's this korean restaurant that
has been around for a while it's like a
jig or a quick place she
means super stew please and she says
that she typically
typically gets this due all the time and
somebody's recording this altercation
where she's yelling at the owner saying
like hey i normally get this i know what
this should taste like and this is way
too spicy oh my god
right and then this korean guy goes this
is not too spicy
i know i'm supposed to feel bad but just
his response is funny these are not
spicy these are not spicy
that's how he has to get his point
across he has to use the [ __ ]
the connotations with the korean
language
too we were talking about this earlier
that i didn't know but [ __ ] ed blew
my mind
so you guys know [ __ ] like uh like pit
by rising
at this show called west coast customs
yeah so basically on the show
and pimp my writer for for you guys who
are young who don't know what the [ __ ]
is it was a show with like exhibit
exhibit was the host yeah people would
have these [ __ ] janky [ __ ] up cars
and exhibit would get these special
people to come in and flip these cars
and make a gangster as [ __ ] yeah i'm
talking about
not just subwoofers there'll be a grill
inside there'll be dildos on the wall i
don't know what the [ __ ] is it
like a tv screen on the [ __ ] wheels
yeah like for some reason
crazy [ __ ] it was just over the top
insane like
like a [ __ ] rice cooker in the
backseat or some [ __ ] yeah but explain
the west coast customs episode okay so
uh if you notice like if you look back
at those cars
those colors were horrible right those
color matching like the interior
never matched with the exterior colors
and then
um now mind you like west coast custom
has been on tv
for over a decade they've been on
multiple channels like after they left
pimp my right they had their own
documentary shows across different
networks
and at one point um i guess a bunch of
their customers were just complaining
about the
the colors schemes of their interiors
because there's a guy named
ish who does all the the um
what is that called leather work uh
upholstery upholstery yeah for the
interiors
his name is ishmael by the way yeah and
so they call him ish for short
um he's a latino he's a mexican do i
believe
and ishmael ishmael and the
owner ryan and hi and him always get
into fights
they get into fights every single
project over the interior colors
and to the point where ryan says dude
you're colorblind right
we need an orange and a green setup
right and then
pulls out this this color of green that
is a
bright neon like i'm talking about like
you know those signs that you would see
in the hood where they're like 99 cents
off and it's that neon green with like
the
explosion spike type that type of
[ __ ] neon yeah highlighter
seahawks neon game right so
he's like what are you talking about
this this is the color right here
and they're just arguing over and he's
like you know what you're color blind
and he goes no i'm not your color blind
argument over it
so what does he do he [ __ ] takes him
to
a [ __ ] uh optometrist to do
a [ __ ] color test for his eyes
and then the first few he gets okay he's
like that's a five yeah all right now
they're gonna get harder
second page wrong third page
i can't see it like dude they've been on
tv
for years oh my god and they've been
getting an art into arguments and fights
and just getting the wrong
colors of their interiors for all this
time
simply because this guy was colorblind
and he was adamant that he wasn't you
have to understand this is years and
years of work people complaining that
the [ __ ] seats are [ __ ] up
and this dude ishmael which by the way
i'm talking about
as mexican as mexican gets yeah like
when i
heard his his like like typical like
mexican accent it sounded like a white
racist person
imitating a mexican person like you know
when i imitated korean person it's
highly exaggerated yeah
that's what his accent sounded like so
it almost sounded like he was racist i
was like is he making fun of mexican
people
he's like i'm not color blind
like bro what the [ __ ] there's no way
ishmael talks like this
what are you talking about i'm not color
blind
and it was like the funniest yet saddest
thing you see on television for him like
i don't know at this point he's probably
almost close to 40 years old yeah
discovering he's colorblind a master in
his craft
wow having to finally figure out how
he's been getting that musical i'm going
to need to find a new job
i'm not making i'm not doing an
exaggeration of his actions i'm saying
this is exactly how he sounds
look it up look it up look it up on
youtube ishmael colorblind
yeah he reminds me so you remember um uh
the other ed park edric so edric used to
have this worker
that used to work at the clothing
factory because ed isn't clothing he
just secret society and everything i was
a company i'm also a part of um and
they're doing all this other [ __ ]
right he had he had one worker that used
to crack me the [ __ ] up and he was the
guy that would always call for lunch and
every time it was
lunchtime everybody in launch time used
to crack me the [ __ ] up and you know
and him are buddies yeah so one day i
have a clip somewhere but he he told
like you hear eddie goes hey tell my
buddy david so
uh happy birthday he goes happy birthday
[Laughter]
lunchtime
so i took spanish for like a couple
years in high school i don't [ __ ]
remember god damn
man it would help me so much living in
l.a now but i don't remember a damn
thing about spanish
so at one point you did some help and
there was one mexican
kid and his cousin at our school and i
was like the one
asian kid so i mean he's the only guy i
knew to go to
so i was like hey i need some help with
my spanish this podcast is brought to
you by
man escaped my friends have you been
trimming your
ball sack with the same old face
razor your whole life well that just
means my friends that you have pubes in
your mouth and i've
guaranteed you've nicked your balls
multiple times
well no more having a hairy nut sack in
a hairy private place you need manscape
it's sleek it's amazing did i mention
that their lawnmower 4.0 has wireless
charging what in the technology are we
talking about
and by the way ladies out there if your
man doesn't
like shaving that's because he doesn't
have manscape you should get him
a pair of manscaped lawnmower 4.0s have
you noticed that your man also has
nose hairs well guess what have you
heard of the weed whacker
i actually use this all the time those
nose hairs audio sucker so to all my
genius brain listeners get 20 off and
free shipping with code geniusbrain
at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at mansgate.com
and use code
geniusbrain unlock your confidence and
always use the right tools
for the job with manscaped i couldn't
understand a [ __ ] thing you were
saying
really because of that deep accent you
know
because i feel like i'd read something
out miyamoto eduardo
he's like no miyamoto eduardo
yeah i could be like that's local
intonation yeah the internet
was like oh [ __ ] it's so different i
hear like the east l.a
accent or whatever right and it's not
like that for some reason when i heard
people do that mexican accent i always
assume it's like you don't know what
[ __ ] real mexican people sound like
it doesn't sound like that
but some of them do i saw in that video
for the first time like i'm not color
blind
yeah what in the hell is going on that
[ __ ] was so [ __ ] funny
it's like i said it's the saddest yet
funniest clip you could see
you guys have to watch that [ __ ] yeah
ish colorblind
colorblind ishmael well let's go ahead
and talk about a movie
since we haven't done a movie review in
a hot second now i
didn't watch much of this movie at all
now this is a classic movie for most
people the first iteration with michael
jordan
we are talking about space space my
friends
now obviously who's the biggest
basketball star on earth right now
lebron james right right obviously you
know they didn't win the finals or thing
i think the bucks did right
yes i haven't followed basketball in a
long time but i stopped following
basketball once the sonics left seattle
yeah
and [ __ ] okc yeah anyway anyway
bitterness there yeah yeah moving on but
before we get this
here's one of the things that i heard
about space jam that a lot of people
were
you know criticizing space jam for it
was lebron james acting
oh my god which no kidding you know
listen he's a basketball player but
here's the thing too
you know the reason why like you can sit
through the first space jam
maybe i mean because we were kids right
we we liked we knew
the old school looney tunes because they
just be on repeat
you know on tv yeah um
so people like us we we have a
connection with looney tunes even tiny
tunes right or
animaniacs and the other thing is
michael jordan has charisma that's right
right
so even when he's freaking out when he's
going to outer space his yelling he's
just like
oh oh right and what's the
train's doing
like dude can you not scream like
here's the thing right the reason why
i understand and i also give him a
little slack is because i know how
lebron james talks
if you guys ever just want to laugh for
like an hour straight
just go watch sports people get uh brand
deals
literally the funniest thing you'll ever
see in your life hi
my name is i don't know la jon brames
my name is lejean brames i use degree
deodorant
whenever i want to stop the sweat
immediately
bro the one of the worst promos i've
ever seen is [ __ ] justin gaichi ufc
lightweight fight one of my favorite
[ __ ] fighters in the ufc yeah
he has a brand deal set up with uh
trojan condoms
what if you need protection he drunk
guns
what the hell was it like right after a
fight did you see that [ __ ]
if you look at your phone later on but
i'll look it up later yeah but it's
literally just engaging
they give him lines on how to promote or
just like have these jokes about trojan
condoms about
protecting yourself because he's a
fighter it is the worst thing i've ever
seen in my life
well i mean that's the thing though like
some people have charisma
right and and kobe bryant rest in peace
yeah and it helps them
like sell [ __ ] as well while they might
not be the greatest actors
well space jam was based off of
a commercial he did with the looney
tunes for some like i forget what it was
yeah and then they were like let's just
turn into a whole [ __ ] movie right
now this one why did they make this
you kind of like you you look at the
plot too
first uh algorithm what's his name
algae rhythm yeah okay so
he expositions his whole case in the
first
like act to just let everyone know he's
a disgruntled
ai and that he is the bad guy and he's
got this motive
which and then it kind of tells you wait
is
warner brothers the antagonist in this
movie
yeah so the people who made this movie
are the bad guys
yeah i don't even think about that
that's true
and then so another thing lebron the
first act is about how he's a terrible
father
that's [ __ ] right dude he's just like
giving [ __ ] to his son for not playing
basketball
and not only that his kid plagiarizes
nba jam
he's like whoa what is this dude this
movie
you know why it was so hard for me to
watch this movie and i know that people
are saying this is like oh it's a kids
movie it's not for adults
which i think is just the dumbest thing
ever because i've enjoyed many kids
movies that weren't for adults that were
perfectly fine
yeah so what the [ __ ] are some people
talking about also to the reason why it
doesn't make sense like you were saying
like i'm trying to give him a lot of
slack because he's a basketball player
because i know how bad they are right
yeah if you go back to
nba jam with michael jordan right he
wasn't that bad
yeah right which for me it
kind of makes it hard for me to be like
well you know well he's a basketball
player he's not an
actor hey michael jordan did it right
and he did it perfectly fine and he is
definitely not an actor
yeah his acting was so terrible like it
was making me giggle
yeah throughout the whole [ __ ] movie
like i couldn't pay attention to half of
it because of how bad his acting is he
couldn't even
do voiceover work you know i know his
cartoon version is so animated
and then his voice is just like what i'm
robin
it's the worst dude yeah what am i
supposed to do
i'm like bro please you guys have so
much money backing this film
give him a [ __ ] acting acting coach
anything
and there it was there was a little meta
into it because
steven young and sarah silverman are
warner brothers executives
and they're selling him this new idea
right and then they put it on the big
screen and it's an idea
for this movie and
lebron james in the meeting room is
saying this is the worst idea i've
ever heard this is bad really bad and
it's like
you're literally doing it right now this
is the [ __ ] movie
yeah it's the movie and so
you as the movie goes on like we don't
have to talk so much about it but then
you you re-watch it through and you're
just like
what's he selling what's warner brothers
trying to sell too
like the looney tunes back to this the
gen z
who don't give a [ __ ] about the looney
tunes you know what the weird thing is
too and i i know like this is uh maybe
for some people feel like this is a
false comparison but
there's a way to reiterate childhood
nostalgia in in
in the new age now yeah and i'll give a
great example that the new animaniacs
right the new animaniacs did a very good
job of making this thing
yeah it's a cartoon for kids but there's
also a lot of adult jokes in there that
makes sense
right they reiterated a lot of like new
[ __ ]
with the same old comedy sense of humor
that we all could [ __ ] laugh at
right that's what space jam could have
done too
which i didn't understand why they
didn't take that route like it just
didn't make any sense
i mean i think it could have been with
wreck-it ralph
with all those [ __ ] easter eggs all
those [ __ ] cameos right and then
wreck-it ralph 2
where it was just like beyond disney
like all these mega corporations and
and like um all these ips in in
one place and just it soaring through
the roof and
and then because of that they made ready
player one and it was just all of these
[ __ ] ips and all this [ __ ]
and then this sounded like warner
brothers being like oh [ __ ] we own a
bunch of ips too
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah let's sell
[ __ ] nobody cares about like casablanca
nobody gives a [ __ ] about like game of
thrones because it ended
so terribly people stop caring about it
people stop recommending it because it's
gonna end
terribly yeah you know and so it's like
what do you got
the looney tunes sell the looney tunes
okay
and oh my gosh it's just like
it's annoying it's cringy
you know but it's for kids okay let's
sell the looney tunes to kids
you know but then you know at what
part of it are you going to enjoy you
know
when lebron like gives so much [ __ ] to
his son
you know and he's a terrible father
or the fact that the kid is so easily
duped by [ __ ] the algorithm
yeah you know don cheadle it's like
maybe if if he casts a spell on him to
make him turn against his father oh yeah
yeah yeah
yeah it could make sense right like put
some digital chip in his [ __ ] brain
no
like this kid's a [ __ ] idiot yeah
and he he goes right towards stranger
danger
what
films are so [ __ ] irresponsible it
also goes back to the film that we
[ __ ] roasted raya
yeah like it's it goes it falls through
the same issues right
the why why why is this happening why
what do what is the more if it's a kid's
film
what is the moral of the story what are
children supposed to take away from this
nothing his father's an [ __ ] and the
child is dumb this is a stupid family
this is a stupid [ __ ] family it
doesn't it was just
like you have to understand too like
yeah i have a little bit of adhd right
but i
love looney tunes i grew up with it yeah
i couldn't watch it and once again
when we talk about films and you say
that it's just for kids you shouldn't
even be watching in the first place you
can't say that you know why
because a lot of my favorite films are
quote unquote made just for kids right
all the toy stories every pixar movie
exactly
right and if we want to talk about a
great [ __ ] pixar movie i'm not sure
if you saw it you see luca
not yet no luca was absolutely you
should watch it and we'll talk about it
later but
that's also a film that was made for
kids but it made
[ __ ] sense there was a great through
story and a moral to it the animation
was [ __ ] amazing
right like we can see these things
objective there was another there was
another animation film too where it was
about robots taking over the world it
was on netflix
[ __ ] uh oh the mitchells yeah the
musicals versus the machines
[ __ ] yeah so good how [ __ ] good was
it so good because the same people who
made spiderverse
okay well that makes sense then yeah
that film was
so [ __ ] good phil lord and
christopher miller
all their films are great all of them
they make they made
21 and 22 jump street right a [ __ ]
r-rated like you know movie for us to
enjoy but then they
understand comedy they understand film
structure and they also made
cloudy with a chance of meatballs they
also made spider-man into the
spider-verse
they make these great and the mitchells
and the machines holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
so by the way too i'm not sure if i've
ever said this on the podcast
i was supposed to be into the spider
verse i was supposed to be in this whoa
so oh you don't know that
no so when i was uh after [ __ ] the film
i was acting i
i got called in because i did uh voice
over work
um i got auditioned to do the voice over
for the asian kid
into the spider-verse his roommate his
roommate and he didn't say anything in
that film right right
the original script he was the comedic
really throughout the whole film oh
i had that role he got cut out
holy [ __ ] so you guys are talking to a
potential oscar winner right here
wait so you recorded lines and then you
just i recorded everything
oh my god and the character got cut and
it was between me and another very
famous actor but that person wasn't
going to get it so when i left the place
they're like oh it's between you and
said guy which you guys don't know who
he is
but the person the uh comes out he goes
just to let you know
i'm 99 percent sure it's you it's going
to be you hey
so just wait for the call get back agent
says they're cutting that character on
they're going a different direction so
it's it's it's not going to work out wow
devastated i was actually like depressed
for like a month
i'm i would be i i was so happy to do
that role
i added all these like comedic beats to
it i was given freedom that's why those
i know amazing amazing directors they
they're so dope
so you were supposed to be the
spider-verse version of ned
in the mcu yeah yeah yeah yeah so that
that character played a bigger role but
he just passed out
yeah so was was that your you passing
out was that your voice
no it was it was not it was not i didn't
get credit for it it was just
but and so but that also led to another
opportunity where i did voiceover work
for uh wish dragon
okay okay yeah so i was in wish dragon
for a little bit
and i was brought in by the way that
director too amazing
like yeah so great uh i was brought in
to audition for
the main villain i didn't get the part
but bobby lee was a part of it there was
another youtuber
that was in it too there's a bunch of
people i think phil wong was in there
too
i gotta check it out i haven't had
there's so much i haven't seen which
dragon essentially is the asian version
of aladdin
okay so so you mean a better version of
riot
yeah exactly so wish i could was
infinitely better than [ __ ] raya and
i i auditioned for the main villain for
that yeah and then
um the director was like oh you actually
do voices really well like it might not
work for this but can you do voices for
all the other side characters so i did
voices for every single [ __ ] side
character all right
and uh they kept kept one of my voices
yeah so i was
i went back like two or three times so i
got paid a day rate to work with the
director to
to develop like character development
for all the side voices okay
yeah so and i got that recommended for
that because of the spider first thing
he recommended me to
um um i forgot his name but amazing
amazing director
so yeah i wanted to [ __ ] die yeah
well you know all you brain farts out
there
just let out a wishful you know fart
for david's next role yeah and then
enemies i was so [ __ ] mad because i
went to go watch
into the spider-verse i was like i bet
you this feels gonna [ __ ] suck anyway
i watched it three times yeah i do it i
love that i watched it three times
in theaters because i liked it that much
yeah and then i cried myself to sleep
for a month
so yeah in my face yeah i didn't tell
anybody about that [ __ ] but yeah i i got
called in to do that audition got called
back
three or four times yeah and they came
out like this is basically yours so just
wait for the call and then that
character was gone
yeah it was probably better off for you
to just not bring it up yeah so there
was the original script it was like
um he came in and he had this power she
goes oh [ __ ] and he's like oh my god
what the [ __ ] is going on like i'm not
the [ __ ]
is like what is this like you have this
power this pad whip and they start
connecting and they're having fun and
he's like the comedic relief throughout
the whole film
yeah so he had a very very important
role in the film but when i watched the
film i understood why they took him out
yeah way too many characters
he would not have fit yeah i was like
very very good move on their part
i wanted to [ __ ] die
the movie's better but yeah i haven't
really done voiceover work since then
because i've been so scarred
yeah like but i would love to do voice
over work again i still have a voice
over agent i just haven't been
auditioning yeah because i'm still a
little better i know it's been two
three years yeah do it man i'm a little
i'm a little sad it's
it's it's your time dude yeah it's all
this
you know asian american media is coming
out i think [ __ ]
you could be in anything dude yeah i
mean i would love to do voice over
working but i wasn't wish dragon for you
guys who don't know
i i played it i'll go home and watch
that yeah
a lot of these like animated films are
[ __ ] killing it mine is space jam
yeah so that's the end so at least the
the first space jam they
actually play play basketball yeah right
and then they have cartoon antics
but then at the end of this space sham
new legacy
they play nba jam you know the old
arcade yep and
um they like have like these thousand
point deficits and [ __ ]
and so without you know
a sense of like actual score keeping
there was no sense of like
urgency right there was no real ticking
clock there was
no like oh like what are we gonna do
is just yeah okay let's just wait for
what they're gonna do next
right i think the weird thing too is for
people who don't want who let's say
these kids who don't know looney tunes
right
a big part of that film's success space
jam the first one
was based on our connection with the
original loon looney tunes cartoon cast
yeah because
the original 50s 60s 70s cartoons were
still running
at that time right and we watched it
religiously so there was no explanation
to who these cartoon characters are
but then when i look at it from a
perspective of let's say these kids
don't know what these looney tunes are
they're like what the [ __ ] is
with this talking duck like you know
what i mean
like what is this [ __ ] what is this
skunk what is this all you know all
these like weird stuff
so it's like i wonder if uh people who
watch that and they don't know what
looney tunes are they're like
where do these [ __ ] cartoons and
characters come from who the [ __ ] are
they yeah like
it's you're just kind of supposed to
know them right in their antics but then
the idea of looney tunes in the original
iteration i believe
is actual mental disorders
oh that's right into cartoon characters
so like bugs bunny is narcissism daffy
duck
is like is a sort of insanity that's why
he'd always go
whatever uh elmer fudd was you know
that's you know slow yeah and
uh porky pig had a bad stutter you know
um so yeah tasmanian double up just
hyperactivity and all these things so
they represented
um mental disorders into a children's
cartoon
you know how lovely for kids to watch
and
obviously they're kind of kind of get
away from that and just kind of
expect people to know that these are
these people's characters but then if
you don't know where the [ __ ] they are
why the [ __ ] are you gonna put in like
the wizard of oz like
how many kids are watching wizard of oz
exactly who's gonna [ __ ] know
um casablanca when it got to the black
and white film i
kind of didn't get where it was yeah
neither did i yeah
like the only things you did even when i
was younger i probably still wouldn't
have understood that [ __ ] either yeah me
neither i
we our parents didn't show us casablanca
exactly i was just listening to [ __ ]
icon with the wind and hearing my mom
[ __ ] praying in the middle of the
night
we have to watch like bible stories
exactly probably watch king of egypt
god dude [ __ ] charleston has tarleton
hessing his [ __ ] all those films
yeah dude oh the ten commandments i was
talking about the animated one
oh yeah the king of egypt you will win
oh that's right
i actually don't remember too much of
that but i know [ __ ] the 10
commandments childhood tests i watched
that [ __ ]
so [ __ ] much the two vhs ones
what was that [ __ ] uh parody that
they did of the childhood where they
were there was like 15 commandments and
he dropped the tablet and cracked them
and then he was like
i give you ten commandments no was that
like a
monty python it might have been a monty
python thing but that [ __ ] was so
[ __ ] funny they're just clowning on
the bible the whole time
and that was part of the life of brian
dude i was laughing at that sketch and i
felt like i was gonna go to hell yeah i
was like
i shouldn't be laughing but this is so
funny yeah i mean
going back to the original point like
kit like some movies are made for kids
right and you're not supposed to stress
about them
but at the same time if you were a
parent like you want to show your
kids stupid [ __ ] because you believe
your kid's dumb
anyway and like she's not going to get
it they're just going to like colors
right
yeah yeah um like it's like the whole
reason why like
i just learned like you're not supposed
to baby talk
to toddlers you're supposed to talk to
them regularly so that they learn
language yeah efficiently right i think
uh the artist you had here he
he had mentioned that yeah yeah yeah
like there's
there's all this like weird stuff too
like when you go into like childhood
psychology so i have a friend who's like
a child therapist and um
specifically uh she deals with uh
she thought that she deals with it but
she was telling me about certain things
um about like child like even speech
therapy
right so she was talking about a problem
that parents have now in like the new
age
so we have like the second generation of
people who um
don't want their kids to suffer this
seems to be the ongoing theme you see it
on twitter
i shouldn't feel pain i shouldn't feel
bad people made me feel bad
right which for me i'm just like you're
shut the [ __ ] up like it's gonna happen
um not to say your feelings aren't valid
but
you got to accept pain as a part of life
it's part of growth
so a lot of these parents now are having
trouble with their kids not being able
to speak at an early age
they can't communicate and the reason
why is because parents are having an
issue with always doing things for their
kid so for example
if a kid wants something right let's say
these little wonderful uh coasters from
ecuador
and before the kid goes i want those
coasters
right the kid will go open their mouth
and the parents will go oh do you want
these coasters
[Laughter]
kids about to say something else oh do
you want a glass of water
and they're speaking for their kids all
the [ __ ] time so these
these people who are like child speech
uh speech therapist this is one of the
biggest issues that they're dealing with
because their parents are coddling these
kids so much
so kids are just going exactly and
they're not learning how to speak
because they're speaking for their
[ __ ] kids all the [ __ ] time right
another thing that uh
that they were uh my best friend was
telling that
their pediatrician friends are talking
about a lot of these kids are getting
sick
because their parents are such germ
germophobes they're not allowing their
kids to go ahead and build up their
immune system right so what i found out
through him and the pediatrician is that
a lot of kids children small children
they develop a stronger immune system
by crawling around and sticking their
hands in their mouth but they'll stop
them from doing that but they actually
need that for those germs to build up
their immune system yeah it's actually a
very natural part of life
but they won't let their kids do that so
the kids have weaker immune systems
their motor functions are [ __ ]
because of this babying thing that's
happening right
so i mean back to the topics of bad
kid movies yeah right so if you
show too much content of of like baby
talk videos
like well into like when they're in
their toddlers or even turning four or
five
that's like as if you're still bottle
feeding them
it's right it's it's as if they're still
in diapers at that point
so it's like at that point too i would
imagine like you would want a more
comprehensive
children's movie kids aren't dumb dude
they learn they're sponges
like they learn they learn from these
morals of things that are right and
wrong
like when we talk about kids films oh
leave these kids film they're made for
kids
you tell me right now as an adult you
don't like [ __ ] aladdin
that's also a kid's film yeah one of the
best animated films of all time
yeah and yeah and what was the moral of
that right it was about being yourself
being true to yourself in that life
right and then who had the same
kind of motive wonder woman 84. yeah
the same wish concept but it was like
what the [ __ ]
is this and you realize oh
this version of wonder woman is a
children's film yeah
but it's like whoa what are you teaching
them yeah and we can go through this
thing and you know what's so interesting
too when you were bringing up the whole
i actually forgot to mention this but i
think uh winnie the pooh
originally too like those characters
were supposed to be a mental thing as
well right
yeah like uh you are obviously very uh
a depression kind of thing and um
yeah yeah i forget that was rabbit yes
yes yes
right and tigger was a hyperactivity
yeah
and it was showing how all of these
emotions
of these these different um characters
live together and their friends together
and how they deal with each other you
know
have you seen the uh christopher robin
movie was it
have i seen christopher was it the
live-action one it was a live-action one
where they had winnie the pooh and so
christopher robin obviously through like
world war
ii or whatever starts to grow up he
becomes a little hard and forget about
forgets about his happiness in his
childhood was it the one with
you and mcgregor yes i believe right and
then uh when
the pooh gets wind of it he goes into
the tree and he finds christopher robin
as an adult and tries to remind him of
himself
yeah that [ __ ] movie made me cry like
yeah it was so touching
i bawled my [ __ ] eyes out and you
know what the crazy thing is too
yeah that's a kid's movie but as an
adult i actually related it
related to it a lot right because that
the more
the moral of that story is too is that
we forget our personal happiness because
we feel that as an adult we need to
always behave and do things a certain
way
we always push our personal happiness
aside to conform to what everybody else
says
about their definition of what happiness
what an adult should be
right and it reminded me of kind of how
i
used to live my life too prior to me
doing the film prior to me doing all
this other stuff
it's like you we we forget to kind of
take care of our inner child and learn
how to be happy
winnie the pooh is my favorite disney
character of all time
so many real quotables when i have a kid
it's going to be winnie
the pooh quotes and everything all over
amazing quotes amazing life lessons
all the [ __ ] time yeah if you look up
just winnie the pooh quotes every single
one that makes me cry
yeah and all that we need the poo stuff
was like way back when when did they
do it when were they like 50s or 60s
right yeah
you look at children's content starting
from the 90s
where did it [ __ ] go wrong why did we
get [ __ ] like
barney when did it become about singing
and dancing when did it become about the
mickey mouse club when did it become
about you know like
sing along is great like i remember you
know the
it'd be like karaoke with classic disney
like show tunes or whatever right
um but then outside of that like
i feel like sesame street's the only
ones who's still doing with like dealing
with
real issues and crises like within the
modern american families right yeah
yeah but i actually i started watching
all over again uh family matters
right right and i love jaleel white i've
actually had conversations with
jaleel white through my um uh dms and
stuff
wow shout out to jaleel white uh he has
a company called a purple oracle
yeah i saw yeah picture you dressed up
like urkel again
it's like it's like a wee company yeah
purple oracle shout out to that company
check it out
not getting paid for it i just [ __ ]
with jaleel white so much too because
watching that show made me realize how
much of his [ __ ] i absorbed
yeah right yeah like i forgot this
phrase it used to be like
one of the jokes i used to use all the
time because you used to make people
laugh it was
i don't have to take this i'm going home
you know but that show was so [ __ ]
funny because it reminded me of the key
and peel sketch
where they where they had um it wasn't
julia white but it was the actor who
plays
chris and everybody hates chris and he
plays steve urkel
and so in this sketch you see jordan
peele he plays carl winslow
and he's talking to the writer he's like
i'm sick of this like
you have me doing all this stupid
[ __ ] [ __ ] i never understood the
sketch because i don't remember family
matters being like that
yeah and then what i saw throughout the
season is that throughout the season
what people actually may or may not know
jaleel white's character steve
urkel was not supposed to be a permanent
cast member right he wasn't even the
main character right yeah
yeah but every episode basically after
the first season
was about steve urkel yeah because he
hit
so well on the uh so high on the ratings
yeah and so that sketch was about how
everything was about urkel
and how ridiculous the show was yeah it
wasn't about family matters it was about
article matters
exactly it was crazy because i was
watching and i'm like wait hold on a
second is he going to space
wait that's right stefan raquel he made
a he made a machine that could
that has a cool gene yeah wait he had a
teleporting pad that sends him out all
the way to paris
yeah what the [ __ ] oh wait he steps in
the transforming machine and he turns
into [ __ ] elvis
yeah so like it started getting more and
more ridiculous
like way later right because in that
initial first season he he was what many
families in suburban america have is
that annoying kid who just always comes
by or something right yeah
and he was supposed to be like so there
was family matters back to back with
full house
right and that character in full house
is kimmy
right she was that annoying neighbor who
was just kind of unwelcome but
dj's best friend right yeah and so he
was
that version in family matters but then
his charisma and character
like the the what's that called when
then when they just
kind of survey a bunch of random people
while watching the show
i know what you're talking about yeah
people just [ __ ] loved urkel
right and so they shot him to the
forefront of everything right
dude did you come across the episode
where urkel gets saved
no i don't remember that one oh my gosh
there's an episode where steve urkel
goes to church
and he goes to the altar and he's like
i've accepted the lord
into my heart right and then the entire
audience
cheers like this is the 90s of like
conservative america i guess
like because in the suburban homes like
so many people were christians
yeah it's such a weird episode to watch
today
like because who would do that these
days they had so many musical guests
yeah they had like black street they had
uh i forgot what her name but she she
played on oona
do you remember anunna she was like the
the nerdy she's a very very famous
r b singer [ __ ] i can't believe i'm
forgetting her name i [ __ ] love her
um
this podcast is brought to you once
again by purple they have been
sponsoring this podcast because
i want them to be a sponsor because i
sleep on their stuff
it is amazing and i know what you're
thinking why should i
invest into another mattress when i
already have one you don't have a
mattress you have a sack of sadness that
you sleep on
you have no idea what you're missing out
on because you have not
blessed your back your buttocks your
side your stomach whatever type of
sleeper that you
are with a purple mattress we're talking
about their patented technology grid
that keeps you cool and comfortable
because i sleep hot
it's hot as hell lately and guess what
your boy has his sweat
a single drop in his sleep because
purple somehow
is super comfortable super ventilated
super cool and amazing
amazing amazing so stop sleeping on your
bag of sadness get yourself
a purple mattress a purple product
purple anything
i also use their purple cushion when i
sit down to help
my booty check it out genius brain
listeners purple is comfort reinvented
right now you'll get 10 off any order of
200
or more go to purple.com brain10 and use
promo code brain10 that's purple.com
brain10 promo code brain 10 for 10
off any order of 200 or more purple.com
brain 10 promo code brain 10 terms apply
but she was on una she had [ __ ] they
had a uh
not larry bird [ __ ] uh grandmama
uh larry johnson i want to say larry
johnson but
charlotte hornets yes yes the grap the
granny shot yeah
everybody imitated the granny shot
because of that yeah yeah but
that's how you shoot his free throws it
was [ __ ] hilarious but
so many [ __ ] guests and it got to
that point too dude
do you remember this that so
times are different right you also talk
about like conservative america when he
said he accepted the lord
jesus savior christ everybody's turning
their [ __ ] head off yeah do you
remember
a character that he played that would
not pass in today's
cultural climate there was a female
version there was so that's that's
myrtle urkel
right but another character that he
played that that when he went into this
machine he became a fighting machine
who did he become asian person what
i don't remember this one bruce lee you
don't remember urkel as bruce lee
no dude so he would go into the machine
right
he would come out of it and he was bruce
lee and he would start beating people up
that's not the crazy part and i don't i
still don't find it offensive yeah but
in today's climate you wouldn't be able
to do it he comes out and he goes
why hell well my name is blues
yeah so you want tuabo oh hello big guy
you don't want to come here and it's
like i'm not [ __ ] sh and i saw that
[ __ ] and i was like i was cracking up
and i remember as a kid i couldn't wait
until he turned into
blue suite please more boo
sweet yeah that accent is exactly what
he sounded like and there was an episode
where carl turns into bruce lee too
both of them so in this episode they're
about to get jumped by these bikers this
biker gang or whatever
and then carl and him he goes well let's
let's hey big guy let's just go and
by the way four thousand episodes he had
to do that voice yeah
wow
yeah that's like hard to take right now
yeah he would go
he went they went into the machine carl
and him
winslow go in and they could both come
out with bruce lee with the bowl cut and
the outfit
a pull cut the bowl cut and the f look
just look it up on your phone right now
put [ __ ] put a steve urkel bruce lee
hello hello silly guy you want to get
the tuabo
let me look this [ __ ] up it's [ __ ]
crazy
and when i look at that i'm like dude
times were really different i still
don't find it offensive because i like i
said i remember watching that and
wanting to see it again and it happened
three times throughout the show
and i'm just oh my god
oh [ __ ] that's a crazy ass [ __ ] face
with with the accent oh my gosh okay so
that also reminded me of another episode
where um there's just this locker room
talk
right with eddie right and so the rumors
are swirling
and towards the end carl
corners his son eddie and he's like son
i need you to tell me
are you a virgin and then he goes
yes dad the crowd erupts in chairs
that's hilarious those are the classic
episodes that i remember
like i don't know i blocked out this
bruce lee stuff
dude there's all this other stuff too
there's like an episode where laura
wants to go out and party and uh
she's like dressed in this you know at
that time i guess very revealing dress
but it was a skin-tight dress
and her father's you know giving her a
lecture about how
you know you don't want people to judge
you by the dress that you're wearing
right you want people to respect your
mind
but nowadays it's like that body you
could do whatever the [ __ ] you want
don't let a man tell you what to wear
the the rhetoric has changed so much
since the 90s i mean
the the funny part though was that
family
matters was running on abc fresh prince
of bel-air
was running on nbc and they were
covering all that [ __ ] without that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah yeah right they were just more or
less like hillary banks was all about
that [ __ ]
right um even ashley was trying was when
she was coming
into age and people were trying to
protect her all the time
and she sings that song that she just
wants a little i forget what song she
actually sang
but yeah there's so many of those things
that i think that's why like i kind of
lean
way towards fresh prince yeah yeah and i
probably just stopped watching family
matters after it just got ridiculous
do you remember uh steve urkel's
girlfriend two myra yes
so you know she passed away at the age
of 22. wow from stomach cancer
so she passed away like not too long
after the show ended she
yeah damn that's a bummer yeah i mean
that's like
the yellow ranger original yellow she's
that from a car accident right
cancer as well yeah oh [ __ ] i didn't
know that i thought
and i was like as a kid when i found out
that she passed away i think i was like
it was pretty young though that she
passed away and i'm thinking like dude
you're powering don't you just jump out
the car
[ __ ] dumbass if you wanna
you want to take it make this the bummer
episode do you remember
ducky from land before time yes yep yep
she died before the movie came out
her father murdered her and her mother
get the [ __ ]
out of here yeah yeah such a [ __ ]
bummer
really really and then they made like
nine more movies and recast her like
with different people but
yeah that original voice of ducky
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] me dude i love
lamb before time ducky was the best so
sweet
yeah yeah and then if you see her real
life photo too oh my gosh what a sweet
cute looking girl
and [ __ ] father murdered her
so this is the bummer genius brain dude
all this like hollywood [ __ ] man yeah
even when we talk about this like
everybody's on the whole free brittany
thing
yeah right and uh it was like the whole
she's under a conservatorship
yeah her father basically owns her whole
life it's it's pretty [ __ ] nuts man
yeah
and i've been watching so many things
about like childhood
uh actors and how they're turning out
and it does go
to say something about this industry
that [ __ ] people up
right it's just not normal for people to
grow under this much spotlight
it's very [ __ ] odd yeah like to have
that much attention that much power and
that much pool at such a young age
but then we also make them the
sacrificial lamb well
like they we [ __ ] them up too
like we're like you know we we lift them
up
just because we want to see them crash
and burn it's trauma porn men
yeah people love [ __ ] trauma porn
they they are
specifically looking for things to
either gossip about
hate some hate hate about can i just
tell you this too so i had an instagram
live and i'm not sure if you if you were
there
on this part if you watched this part of
the instagram live there was a girl that
i brought on
and she was like in a library and she
had her earphones on
sweet girl but then she started telling
me all this youtube drama stuff like oh
did you hear about this oh did you hear
about this did you care about this
okay so she was talking about like um
rice jump
rice uh rice gum yeah um
he basically promoted this crypto scam
to a bunch of kids people also [ __ ] ton
of money wow
right and then she goes oh did you also
hear about this drama did you also hear
i'm like wait hold on a second what do
you do all day
[Laughter]
and then she starts going into all these
intricacies about every [ __ ]
and i literally told him in the
instagram live i was like i'll be honest
with you i don't know who the [ __ ]
you're talking about
like what is this stuff that you're
talking about like i don't know she goes
oh so i have a
i have a group chat where me and my
friends we just gossip about all the
stuff that's going on
that's all she does all day it's
the gen z tabloid yeah they sit around
and they gossip about celebrity gossip
all day yeah [ __ ] insane
isn't that what the shade room is at the
end of the day kind of yeah
um profile and it was weird that she was
telling me stuff is she
she was trying to connect to me and i'm
like i hope you know
i didn't say this to her right and like
i said sweet girl if you're a fan i love
you to death thank you for supporting me
but yeah
cut that loser [ __ ] out like that's some
of the most
you are so invested into other people's
life that you don't know [ __ ] about
yourself
yeah how [ __ ] sad is that like once
again fan i appreciate you so much
but everybody was roasting her in the
comments like what the [ __ ] are you
doing you loser if all you know
is other people's [ __ ] that's all you
know
yeah and that's all you got to talk
about when you're doing ig live to for
people to ask you
questions but it's like have you heard
yes
have you heard have you heard did you
know about this and i'm like oh thank
you for letting me know this stuff cool
very about you
what about you maybe her question should
have been how do i get over this [ __ ]
lifestyle
yeah like the the most poison and those
are the people too
that really end up getting personally
hurt from comments
that sit around and steal around trying
to destroy people all day because this
is the world that they live in this is
where they feel empowered
it's not [ __ ] real like okay so let's
role play
if i was hurt david i can't stop talking
[ __ ] about people who have
no direct correlation to my life what do
i do i stay up all night till 6 a.m
reading all these uh you know youtube
tabloids about
the beef between this youtuber and that
youtuber what do i do
and guys it's like dude you're a [ __ ]
loser
yeah cut that [ __ ] [ __ ] out what the
[ __ ] are you talking about you're so
invested in other people's life that you
don't have a life of your [ __ ] own
how sad is that [ __ ]
like literally i could tell that this
person doesn't have much friends and
they're
and this person's friends is probably
the people that are in that little chat
room right they've never really met each
other and all they do is talk [ __ ] and
gossip all day and they think that
they're
that's friends let me tell you guys
something if you develop bonds through
talking [ __ ]
those aren't real friendships yeah you
never develop good stuff because
i know a lot of people who not know
i've known a lot of people who have
actually confronted about this bad
behavior
of connecting through people by talking
[ __ ] and those friendships never last
they they enjoy the fact that they're
the source of knowledge about all the
negative stuff and people oh i want to
hear more
oh you hate that person too me too
exactly
besties yeah it's like
oh you have a common enemy so that's why
you're friends like that happens
in war exactly there's no found
strong foundation for a friendship at
all and in fact like i
witnessed something about somebody that
i that um not not too long ago that i
was like okay
we can kick it every now and then but
you and i are not friends
because this person had issues with
another friend of mine
but when we were at this gathering in
the party
he was talking to this person
um perfectly fine right yeah saying like
oh you're my closest friend like i
understand because
are our other mutual friend they were
having issues with
and they're like yeah i can't believe
that person would say that to you
honestly i feel like i'm way closer to
you than them
and then i don't know whether he forgot
that i was there
at that party or not but then we because
it's a mutual friend of ours we also got
invited to have dinner at that person's
house as well yeah
and then he starts talking [ __ ] about
the person that they said that they're
way closer to
so yeah i can't believe you know what
they were saying over there they're
trying to [ __ ] brainwash me i was
like hold on a second dude
you just thrive off a [ __ ] gossip
you're just a yes man you [ __ ] [ __ ]
made [ __ ]
and yeah this is a dude that's what i'm
saying
i was like i completely don't respect
this person anymore i i think i
might know what you're talking about
because i have um
certain problems with a guy who had
hosted a party too
right and i was invited
but because i know about the way i feel
like i know it would be great food i
know this will be great company
i know there's gonna be lots of people i
i haven't seen in a while
but in my honest head i was like i'm
gonna get triggered
by this guy i'm i'm gonna feel some type
of way and i don't even understand
why i don't like them i'm not going to
go searching for it either
you know and i'm not going to find
affirmation in other people like do you
also not like this
about this person yeah yeah yeah no the
best thing for me to do is not gulp
yeah the best thing to do and that's
what i didn't do yeah
i was so shocked because and this is and
the reason why i brought that up was
just to go back to the fact that the
only way this person knows how to bond
with people is to find a common enemy
yeah right come on man and just
agreeable with anybody as long as they
can find a common enemy
and just the day before at a different
party he was saying different [ __ ]
to the other person like how do you live
like that
like how how do you [ __ ] live like
that no they don't have real connections
and this person that's supposed to be
their really close friend
they don't have a real connection they
all know it they fight all the [ __ ]
time and the reason why is because they
bonded over something that's as weak
as talking [ __ ] about one person this
guy sounds like he must actually hate
himself but he can't understand why
it's just projecting it on other people
oh it's the saddest thing you should see
this dude in his personal relationships
it's like
the biggest [ __ ] you ever seen in your
life dude just gets verbally bashed and
berated all the time
uh by a significant other and we just
watch and you see this fool just in the
sunken place just cooking
like i've literally witnessed this guy
like his his uh wife called him a
[ __ ] full-blown [ __ ] in front of us
called him an idiot and a [ __ ] and a
[ __ ] and he was like oh yeah i deserve
it
oh my gosh come on man bro come on man
have some dignity
have some type of date and also too that
woman is like
[ __ ] calling him a [ __ ] in front of
company and guess like
that's what's your man
imagine this if if she would say that to
him in public what was she what's she
saying to him behind doors
yeah oh [ __ ] i mean it's much worse than
the
r word exactly that's what i'm saying
like legit call them a [ __ ] in front
of us in front of their kid too by the
way
so it's like ah good god good god
almighty in front of their [ __ ] kid
and i'm like
wow and i'm like sitting here just
seeding yeah but i'm not saying anything
because number one and i'm like you
chose to be in this situation and we've
advised you not to and you're still
doing it because you feel like this
person's the only person for you
and you're a terrible person that you
would call somebody that you supposedly
love
a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i mean it sounds
like
abuse influenced by a lot of cattiness
around his life
where other people around him are
behaving that way and he just seems that
oh this is how
you know this is how people behave this
is how friendships
survive and oh it's so normal not to
have a long lasting relationship
yeah and now i'm just amicable with them
and it's like
i choose not to be around that so we
don't really hang out much anymore
yeah and i'm pretty sure they're
wondering how come you know he doesn't
hit me up and if i did you will hear
everything
but i'm trying to learn how to be nicer
to people so now i'm just like once they
hit me up
yeah we'll we'll grab lunch but you're
not in my inner circle
like never really was in the first place
but
you know it's like i can't deal with
that [ __ ] it's hard for me not to say
something that's why so i have like you
i just can't be in those situations yeah
i mean like cause
i'm not gonna lie i do feel some type of
way about certain people
around me yeah you know but it's not on
me to go
around telling people about what i hate
about this person
yeah who the [ __ ] are we you know not
because i'm trying to
you know i don't want them to know that
i hate them it's like what purpose does
it serve if they did know i hated them
you know um and so i'm like well that's
him
and that's his character right and he
seems happy
he seems fine being that way and you
know what and he's got plenty of friends
so who am i
to be like oh but that he that guy's
such a piece of [ __ ] or maybe it's like
maybe
we're not meant to be friends yeah a lot
of people
do sometimes they think that other
people are [ __ ] when really it's
just that you guys just don't vibe
that's all like it's it's okay too and i
hear a lot of people who talk [ __ ] about
some other people where they're like oh
this person's this and that was like
or you guys just don't get along like
they don't have to be an enemy
yeah it's just more like you guys are
from two different [ __ ] worlds yeah
that's all that it is yeah for sure well
guys that wraps up this episode of the
genius brain podcast we talked a little
bit about space jam some other animated
films my depression
[Laughter]
my [ __ ] deep-seated depression yeah
sign up for better help right
yep sign up for better help i'm on that
i'm on it hey
uh not any sponsored guy but you know
since you told me to sign up
yo it's been great it's dope yeah i
talked to mine i actually had a session
not too long ago
um with my therapist and it was [ __ ]
though it was crazy i mean we're
supposed to end this podcast
just a just a quick thought there's some
something about a therapist
that people don't understand you become
the most honest human being ever because
it's like a moment where you could say
how you feel without feeling like you're
going to be judged
right and you just say stuff i i would
say telling this person's stuff
that i don't think i told mario yeah or
my brother or anybody
right because i feel like i can get this
off my chest i could be vulnerable i can
cry in front of this person
without feeling judged yeah tell you
something bawling my eyes out about [ __ ]
that i didn't think that bothered me
yeah right and then like and they just
listen yes i'm like oh
this is so nice yeah you know but that's
like the the healing part about therapy
is being able to be in a non-judgment
zone
and kind of hash out your thoughts right
and then ask somebody who's credible for
advice you could say some [ __ ] that you
never thought was a part of you or
like very uncharacteristic but still be
validated in your feelings
yeah even though there was like a
language you used that isn't something
you're used to
100 but then well but these feelings are
real yeah right
yeah well guys that wraps up this
episode of the jesus brain podcast you
can catch ed park at ed parkvp
and also catch him at bible study at
momo bible study at momo's check out his
podcast really fun stories
and we will see you all next time peace